[Music]
[Applause]
uh the hall of famer dicky b
joining us on the program dick good
morning what do you remember about that
first game on espn
i remember getting there real late dad i
had no idea that production meetings
nobody ever told me anything it was like
chaos so i'm walking the streets of
chicago
finally i come to the game this is a
true story man i come to the game about
six hours 6 20 6 30 and the producer is
going nuts
there's no iphones in a day he said
we've been trying to call the hotel
leave him out i said i haven't been at
the hotel i said walk the street i said
what's the big problem someone got a
game
i said we got over an hour to go i said
i'm just gonna talk basketball i had no
clue what i was doing
uh guys talking in my ear you know they
hired jocks like us out of the locker
room
and the critics started critiquing i was
lucky that era
because we didn't have critics there
right in all those columns
but it worked out 42 years dad in a bank
and i just signed an extension so i
really i've been blessed i've been
blessed man
working with guys like you over the
years and different colleagues that have
helped me so much
i've been a lucky guy but did anybody
try to
make you a little more polished when you
first started out
you know not really i think they all
told me basically i remember scottie
connell always telling me
you know you got three things he was
like trying to convince me not to go
back coach
in college i wanted to coach in college
that's where i belong
that's where i put my enthusiasm along
not the nba and
got the ziggy in the nba after 12 games
my second year
and i was down i was really depressed
man i'll tell you i'm sitting home
feeling sorry it wasn't my wife kicking
me out of the house practically
when scotty called me up to say i want
you to do our first game
uh he heard about me because my last
game as a college coach
we played number one michigan in the
sweet 16 when it was the university of
detroit
and they decided to televise the game it
was nbc
scottie connell doing the game i was in
or
john wooden's going to be the analyst
kurt gowdy
the legendary to play my play and i damn
this is a true story
i called a me at my team over i asked
scotty
i said can i have my share a few words
to my team
about the two gentlemen doing our game
and i give a five-minute speech about
how
in sports we use the term greatness so
often i said but this
epitomizes greatness right here ten
national championships
all kinds of emmys and sports right guys
i'm honored
i'm in my thirties that people think i'm
enthusiastic now you should've seen me
there
so we got it was a big game for us
because it was david
goliath they wouldn't play us my first
year there we
beat them and upset that michigan with
campanella russell remember him
and we beat them and after that i
couldn't get johnny way to get them on
the schedule
so our players all that year we won 21
in a row would be mark kevin two months
later
won the national championship we beat
arizona michigan state
and by players who come in every day
coach why can't we play michigan they're
number one in the country we're as good
as they are
we play with those guys in the summer i
said man i don't want to hear it didn't
want to play us
i can't hear my assistant runs in after
the
season's over and he hears that the
periods are out and he comes running
into my office and he says y'all could
have believed this
if we get to the sweet 16 we play
michigan oh my god i called the team
meeting i got all the players down there
i said you want michigan
there they are well we play that game
and we lose a heartbreak
i was told later by scotty that when i
got fired by the pistons and he called
me up
i wrote your name down because kirk
county and john wooden will leave in the
arena
so i love that guy's passion and spirit
and he said you should hire scotty and
tvs but i just
been named the head of a new network for
remotes hiring talent more or less
and he said i'd like to hire you our
first game oh i suppose
and he says espn i sent him the true
story there i said
espn that sounds like a disease what the
hell's espn
are you kidding me you know what it's
been a disease for me
and the four letters for me have given
me a life that's exceeded any dream i
ever had
what's the job you almost took to leave
espn was there
a head coaching job that you nearly left
for
a job i was trying to get nobody really
knew it except one guy found out
they roasted me in detroit the universe
to make a lot of money and i told him if
you roast me i gotta pick the roasties
jimmy v was one of my guys i picked so
jimmy v gets up now he wants to be last
is abe lemons jimmy v
chuck bailey uh i had a hell of a cast
and we raised a lot of money
but jimmy gets up to speak at the end he
made sure he said i want to go last
he goes in his pocket and he says i want
to read this letter
to all you beautiful titan lovers here
in the universe detroit about your
coach here who you guys loved he said
this is the letter
dear dick we are sorry to inform you
that we have decided to go
in a way of hiring jim valvano as our
next coach
he said put this in your memory book
and he said he found when he got the job
there he found that letter in the files
and he wanted to make sure i had it but
i i don't think i would have got the job
at all but that was a job i was
interested in
but you know what dan i i didn't know i
did not know what scotty meant you know
the business better than i
immediately i just i'm gonna be a guy
talking about the game
and and the bottom line is he used to
always say to me
the first couple years i was there don't
you don't don't leave this
he said you got something that's rare
you connect with people
whether they agree with you or disagree
they're going to the water cooler and
they say here what dick vitell said
about that thing
and i didn't know what he meant 1983
they assigned me espn my first
my first final four i go there houston's
playing
down here jimmy v louisville georgia
and pitch people coming up with pictures
and autographs and all this
and i i couldn't believe that it's god
he says did i tell you could i
don't that was the moment that i said to
myself you know what i love what i'm
doing
and right now i'll tell you what they
could talk about your chevsky they can
talk about all these great coaches and
their records
i got the best damn record 42 years i
haven't lost the game
i have not lost the game and i coach
every team in america
ucla kentucky north carolina i coach you
all
you got gonzaga trying to go from uh you
know wire to wire here
and i know we love to compare teams and
generations
and you know to me i just say enjoy this
if gonzaga goes undefeated
enjoy seeing something you haven't seen
in a long time
um why is it we want to
it feels like people want to diminish
what gonzaga
could be attempting to do uh by going
undefeated why is that
well that's your sports fanatics you
know sitting like when you argue for
example a baseball player becomes great
how would you compare wooly maze how
would he compare with mickey mouse
that's just a way of life in sports but
i agree these should be related to the
era right now they're the best of the
best
and so somebody can prove to put them on
an l on their
register i said before the seasons
started i said it during the season
and i said it basically before the
tournament started actually
i said 32 and i was happening they're
just that good
offensively damn they execute so well
there's a stat that really impresses me
they lead the nation in assists 18 per
game know what that tells me dan
they're unselfish they share them all
they love playing with each other
and they're much better defensively than
people believe and then the cry will
always get well who do they beat in
their conference
well take a look what they beat
pre-conference kansas bloom
they took they blew off them they took
out uh uh certainly kansas virginia my
memory tells me iowa
blew them on they can play they can play
they know what they got going as well
nobody talks about
i think they're fresh because the
conference wasn't as competitive
as what you've seen in the big ten and
these various conferences so they come
into the tournament
i think physically a lot fresher than
other teams and
they're just a dynamite team now would
they be the greatest team of all time
i don't think there's any shape or form
that they would beat luau cinder and
ucla
because nobody lou i said could take you
me and
take part your guy paul and you know
what we got a chance dad
we're talking to dick vitale the espn
college uh basketball analyst uh signing
a two-year contract extension at the
mother ship
three years dan all three oh oh wow
my bad uh wait did espn make the mistake
that you signed a three year
or two year or did i make the mistake uh
uh you know you were right what you
reported there was an error there
in the initial uh uh release president
it doesn't matter three years but i hope
i have another day tomorrow
when you're 81 years old dad
um i don't know if this is why roy
williams
retired but he had one of his star
players who is uh
deciding to transfer his seven footer
out of georgia
um and this transfer portal was
interesting with college basketball
where do you where is the sport headed
with the transfer portal we've seen this
in football
certainly with quarterbacks now with uh
basketball players
and it's the worst thing that's ever
happened to college basketball i just
put up five tweets
in a row today on twitter if they go to
dickyv they can see them
five of them how it's really got me now
to be honest with you i'm upset big time
about it
because first of all we give it a bad
message to kids look
i understand some cases transfer should
happen
just like i put on twitter in real life
sometimes
the best thing for the couple is the
divorce i mean it's just a way of life
so sometimes a transfer is good then
i'll hear the argument all the time
well coaches leave and they're eligible
right away to play
why shouldn't players well it's not
apples to apples dan we got right now
today
today 1100 players in the transfer
portal
you don't have 1100 coaches come on so
here i
i got a solution for that problem if a
coach leaves
or if he's fired those players should be
automatically
eligible to transfer if that's their
desire so now you wipe that argument out
it's creating such chaos no stability
it used to be years ago you know players
not getting playing time
and you could understand but now we got
starters they won't want to be
recruited again both being chased and
dying than one and those getting hurt
the most in
schools like dayton detroit they will
get a player
to rise to become a real star talent you
can guarantee
word will get out to those kids hey
think about going to this school in the
acc or this school in the big ten
and kids are going to jump i think we're
teaching kids
hey we're teaching kids to quit when
things get tough
life is tough life's not all smooth
right now we got a pandemic that took
close to 600 000 lives we got people
friends of yours friends of mine
lost their jobs but you know what you
got a rally in tough times
and teaching kids oh pack the bags go
and if you were a coach today you look
at the kid the wrong way
he said you know i'm going to transfer
reporter i just think it's the worst
thing
to hit college but and you know what i
have some calls yesterday from coaches
they're up to here with it they're
frustrated you made a good point about
roy williams
i certainly don't believe that's the
only thing but i gotta believe
i remember to remember talking to roy
about oh god
a month ago before doing one of their
games and we were talking on zoom
and we talked about the transfer portal
and he's totally against it
i mean it's it's just really not healthy
for the game of basketball it's just not
healthy at all
and i don't think it's healthy for
everybody involved mark few has said has
told me that
he's had players transferred to him
sitting out the year was the best thing
that happened that everyone became pros
they developed what happened about
developing players
well i don't know what's gonna happen
when we get rid of the one and done
like is basketball gonna be better when
we get rid of the one and done
you know i i'm just worried about the
state of the game
and i think what we need in basketball i
put this on twitter too
we need a czar we need somebody
representing college basketball dealing
with the ncaa
dealing with issues come up dealing with
the nba about the one-and-done and i got
the perfect candidate
i mean you can't get a better candidate
jay billis no
well jay would be great too no he's a
lawyer yeah but jay isn't going to give
up the luxury of tv
without williamsburg is available why
would jay give up
work for the team it's like stealing
money
[Laughter]
i i would love to see billis in that
role because
you know you got to listen to both sides
and uh you know i always appreciate that
billis has
a well thought out answer and i just
don't think i think that
the ncaa is rudderless there there's
there's nobody guiding the ship here
and that's what concerns me not just
basketball but sports
you know across the board dad i agree
with you a lot about jj's a brilliant
mind
does a great job like he's just not
going to leave for something like that
but i will tell you this
i will tell you this i have a real
problem with something else
you got me today where i've got fired up
coaches
out there have been allegations about
cheating
about transcript frauds all those
factors
this happened five years ago it's been
discussed since the fbi investigation
started and no decisions been made here
it is five years
when did they make decisions the ncaa i
don't understand
you know talking they got to go to this
committee that committee give me a break
i mean if you can't solve those problems
within a year and a half two years
there's something wrong something wrong
with the system
and the system's got to get fixed and
they better get on this transfer portal
thing
we should know what man i think might
come july we'll have close to 2 000 kids
transfer it's every day you pick it up
another kid is
i'm going to transfer portal i'm going
to get recruited again
wow can you imagine that you're playing
at dayton and you're on the transfer
portal they'll all be chasing you for
that jump shot you have
they they wanted me to get in the
transfer portal dick
they asked me to leave that's the
problem uh hey congrats
uh on the contract extension and uh
always always great to talk to you dick
thank you
well thank you so much and one last
thing if i could just say this to you
dan quickly
if people can help me raise money for
kids battling cancer but
v foundation just go to dickbytel.com
they can make a donation it goes to the
v foundation
so far we raised 37 million dollars and
i need a lot of help right now
especially with the pandemic so go to
dickfitel.com
thank you buddy